bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 10 février la russie bombarde de
façon intensive en tchétchénie et fait
visiter grozny aux journalistes la
capitale désormais sous son contrôle
notre envoyé spécial dorothée olliéric
sera dans quelques instants en direct de
grozny les attaques informatiques contre
plusieurs sites internet provoque une
réaction du fbi aille aux etats unis une
véritable enquête criminelle digne des
lyonnais cet encours acquise histoire
implacable dans l'instruction en marge
de l'affairé elf contre roland dumas le
procureur demande son renvoi en
correctionnelle pour complicité et recel
d'abus de biens sociaux
il y aura 50 ans demain le salaire
minimum interprofessionnel garanti était
créée il ya 30 ans le smic devenait le
smic
comment vivre avec ce minimum exemple
dans une entreprise de maintenance
industrielle à dunkerque
théâtre le journal de shirley une drôle
de dame américaine des années 70 très
joliment interprétée par judith magre
jusqu'au bout les russes mèneront leur
guerre comme bon leur semble en
tchétchénie aucune critique
internationale n'a changé la volonté des
dirigeants russes aujourd'hui encore des
vagues de bombardements destinés à
préparer une vaste offensive terrestre
avec quelques cinquante mille hommes ont
frappé le sud du pays et des villages
occupés par les forces rebelles
comment tehran consignes et on ne peut
pas dire que la paix soit revenu dans la
ville de grosses ni tout au plus peut-on
constater que le canon a fait le silence
sur un champ de ruines au milieu des
squelettes d'immeubles et des tas de
gravats
les soldats russes ont placé leurs
points de contrôle et les habitants se
demande de quelle nature sera la
cohabitation avec ses nouveaux occupants
puisqu'il n'y a plus de combats chacun
ait tenté de rentrer chez soi mais ce
qui n'a pas explosé a généralement été
pillés j'habitais ici avant maintenant
on dit de rentrer chez moi mais il n'ya
plus de chez moi
elle est où ma maison c'est comme s'il
ne restait que les cases celle que les
habitants de grosses ni ont occupé
pendant cinq mois et dont ils sortent
peu à peu aujourd'hui
affamés et
et et les soldats russes eux aussi
fouillé la ville à la recherche d'armes
selon le ministre de l'intérieur ils ont
trouvé dans un laboratoire les corps de
154 soldats tués lors de la guerre
précédente de 94 96 des morts qu'ils
affirment réclamé avec insistance depuis
cinq ans soucieux sans doute de montrer
qu'il n'y a pas d'embourbement russes en
tchétchénie
l'état major vient d'annoncer que
plusieurs régiments seraient renvoyés
chez eux
il est vrai que toute la plaine du sud
de grozny est désormais sous contrôle
russe
mais les soldats consolide les positions
car la menace est toujours là
un peu plus loin les combats faisaient
rage hier dans les montagnes du sud où
sont désormais retranchés les
combattants tchétchènes
parallèlement l'état major russe permet
des journalistes en groupe de venir sur
place à grozny et dans les environs
notre équipe avec dorothée olliéric ai
dit d'aller sur place
dorothée qu'est ce qu'il vous a été
possible de recueillir comme témoignage
aujourd'hui
tout d'abord je voudrais parler des
soldats russes parce que ça fait deux
jours en fait que nous sommes avec des
soldats russes est officiellement donc
grozny est libérée tout va bien mais
quand nous sommes arrivés ici je suis à
quatre kilomètres de grozny toute
l'artillerie lourde qui se trouve
derrière moi à thenay je dirais une
vingtaine de fois dans la journée
alors on nous dit que c'est dans la
banlieue de grozny et passeur grozny
mais nous sommes allés dans l'après midi
à grozny dans le centre dans le quartier
est et là on a entendu sans arrêt des
tirs d'armes légères
donc il n'ya pas de gros combat mais il
ya encore des obus il ya encore des tirs
à l'intérieur
et selon quelques soldats il y aurait
des poches de résistance importante il
paraît qu'il y aurait peut-être 100
combattants tchétchènes encore
dissimulés et les spas les officiels et
les soldats russes craignent très vite
le retour de ses soldats il retourne
l'offensive et d'une guerre à grozny
merci de noter et puis ce soir vladimir
poutine le président par intérim de
russie se dit tout à fait satisfait de
la situation actuelle en tchétchénie la
suspension de l'embargo aérien sur la
serbie pourrait être annoncée lundi
après les déclarations favorables des
etats-unis de la grande-bretagne et de
la france cependant les sanctions
potentielles visant les partisans
slobodan milosevic pourrait être durcies
tôt ce matin sur l'aéroport de stansted
près de londres ce fut la fin du
détournement de l'avion afghan où 156
personnes étaient retenues en otages
depuis dimanche pas d'effusion de sang
les pirates se sont rendus mais il ya
comme une confusion à propos de demande
d'asile politique que ceux ci auraient
fait ainsi que plusieurs dizaines de
passagers afghans londres le récit de
maryse burgot avec jean piat bassin qui
sont-ils exactement ces afghans qu'on
dirige ce soir vers un hôtel proche de
l'aéroport de stanstead les victimes du
détournement d'avion ou les complices
discret des pirates de l'air
ce qui est très clair en tout cas ce
soir c'est que 60 d'entre eux ont déjà
officiellement demandé l'asile politique
en grande-bretagne
il est 6h ce matin lorsque la police
britannique obtient sans effusion de
sang
la reddition des preneurs d'otages et la
libération de tous les passagers mais
sur ces images déjà on ne comprend pas
très bien qui sont les victimes qui sont
les pirates de l'air
plus tard dans la matinée le chef de la
police reconnaîtra devant des
journalistes un peu surpris que les
motivations politiques des pirates ne
sont pas très claires m non plus bref le
détournement d'avion pourrait être tout
simplement le moyen choisi par un groupe
d'afghans pour demander l'asile
politique en grande-bretagne il ya eu
c'est vrai le précédent des preneurs
d'otages chiraquien en 1996 mais c'est
quand même très rare quelques vols sur
des milliers il est donc difficile d'en
tirer des conclusions
cet après midi le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est d'ailleurs empressé de
dire que les pirates n'obtiendrait
jamais l'asile politique en
grande-bretagne
tout au long de la journée les autorités
ont tenu ce discours de fermeté
histoire de décourager une bonne fois
pour toutes
ceux qui seraient tentés d'utiliser à
nouveau ce genre de méthode pour
débarquer en grande bretagne et demandé
l'asile politique
l'aviation israélienne a recommencé ses
tirs de missiles air-sol au nord de la
zone occupée par israël au liban sud
officiellement ces raids ont été
déclenchées par des attaques d'une
franchise intégré menée contre des
positions israéliennes puis demain le
comité de surveillance du cessez-le-feu
créé en 1996 se réunir à washington le
comité composé de représentants des
états unis d'israël du liban de la syrie
et de la france et puis on a appris
aujourd'hui le président israélien
monsieur désir weizmann avait été
entendu par la police
il est soupçonné de ne pas avoir déclaré
au fisc plusieurs centaines de milliers
de dollars donnés par un homme
d'affaires français à vienne où se
tenait une réunion du conseil permanent
de l'organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe csce les
représentants français belges se sont
volontairement absentés qu'on a un
discours de cette femme
la ministre des affaires étrangères du
nouveau gouvernement autrichien composé
de conservateurs et de libéraux
d'extrême droite de la ministre madame
ferrero waldner a jugé ces réactions
européennes précipitée et
disproportionnée
d'autre part l'annoncé de la venue le 17
février prochain à bruxelles de jorg
haider provoque déjà quelques troubles
en belgique
c'est peut-être une véritable guerre qui
est en train de se développer dans le
monde informatique des sites internet
très importants sont attaqués par
saturation bloquant tout pendant
plusieurs heures des millions de
messages sont ainsi renvoyés sur le net
pour embouteiller les serveurs aux états
unis où ces attaques à répétition
viennent de se produire le fbi a ouvert
une enquête criminelle pour tenter de
savoir qui veut ainsi percer la sécurité
du commerce électronique
explications de notre correspondant à
new york dominique derda avec édouard
perrin festina comme des centaines de
milliers d'américains collectionne des
beanie baby ces animaux en peluche qui
dans ce pays font la joie des petits et
des grands
c'est sur internet sur ebay un site de
vente aux enchères fréquenté chaque jour
par 8 million de visiteurs
quel vent et qu'elle achète ses précieux
joué les mardis catastrophe plusieurs
heures durant ebay ne répondait plus de
vilain petit canard venait de réussir à
bloquer la machine jamais dit le porte
parole de la société
nous avons eu à faire face à une attaque
comme celle ci et ebay n'est pas la
seule visée au total près d'une dizaine
de sites parmi les plus populaires comme
yahoo ou amazon ont été victimes depuis
le début de la semaine de pirates
informatiques qui ont submergé les
serveurs de demandes d'informations
jusqu'à paralyser leurs ordinateurs
centraux
nous sommes déterminés dit janet
non le ministre de la justice à faire
tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir pour
retrouver les responsables et les
traîner devant les tribunaux
c'est le fbi a et qui est en charge de
l'enquêté car il ne s'agit pas
simplement de permettre à quelques
collectionneurs comme christina et c'est
beanie babies d'échangés deux ou trois
babioles mais bien de sauver l'image
d'un des secteurs clés de l'économie
américaine le commerce électronique a
représenté l'an dernier 4 % du volume
des échanges aux états unis et certains
prédisent déjà qu'il atteindra les 50 %
dans dix ans pour lutter contre le
piratage informatique bill clinton vient
de demander au congrès une rallonge de
37 millions de dollars 240 millions de
francs sur le budget de cette année
en attendant pour le fbi a ils enquêtent
s'annonce difficile car non seulement
évidemment il ignore tout de l'identité
des auteurs de ces attaques mais désigne
heurtaux également de leur motivation
oui j'utilise elle vient instant le mot
de guerre et ceux d' enquêtes
criminelles à propos de ces attaques
dont sont victimes des sites comme yahoo
vous états unis devant une telle
criminalité organisée extrêmement habile
la réponse ne peut être que policière
mais pour distinguer les pirates de
simples amateurs imprudent il faut des
spécialistes incorruptibles explications
hervé brusini sur internet on trouve
même les incorruptibles
enfin ceux de la bonne vieille série
télé parce que le redresseur de torts
électronique l'eliott nette des temps
modernes aurait un sacré travail devant
lui un travail où l'adversaire porterait
le nom de kevin mitnick par exemple ce
virtuose du clavier était parvenu dans
les années 90 à pénétrer les réseaux des
plus secrètes installations militaires
américaines
les films noirs game en fit un héros
c'est est ce qu'on appelle un pirate
informatique un coeur comme on dit là
bas il eu le tort de s'attaquer à un ami
souchez mou shimomura lui aussi un as de
la navigation clandestine manque de
chance dans ce combat singulier livrée à
coups de souris shimomura travaillé pour
les services secrets américains 8 nick
chute arrêter ici et mis en prison
quatre longues années défi je vantardise
le hacker peut tout à la fois percé les
protections informatiques et se mettre
au service des autorités répressives
aujourd'hui des amis de mythe ni conte
lignes ouvertes dans une radio à new
york
il y donne les dernières nouvelles du
piratage ils sont d'ailleurs suspecté
parmi d'autres d'être responsable des
dernières attaques massives
une vengeance peut-être après de récents
démêlés judiciaires pour du piratage de
musique bataille combat rivalité pour
tout cela le monde de l'ordinateur
inventer son expression propre l'infowar
où l'info gays sont grands spécialistes
vite ici en floride lui aussi à sa radio
mais payés par bill gates et microsoft
et lui il n'hésite pas à parler de
cyberespionnage c'est vouloir les choses
que vous protéger et 16 développe de
plus en plus de plus en plus de piratage
mais pas par les pirates par des
professionnels un criminel qui font de
l'espionnage
c'est une sorte de guerre une guerre qui
a déjà ses canaux électroniques celui là
par exemple vous détruit tous les
ordinateurs sur un rayon d'un kilomètre
contre roland dumas le procureur de
paris jean pierre dintilhac a rédigé un
réquisitoire de 80 pages l'adresse des
juges d'instruction eva joly et laurence
vichnievsky pour leur demander de
renvoyer l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères devant le tribunal
correctionnel le réquisitoire est
implacable et désormais sur la place
publique puisque le journal le monde le
publie ce qui provoque la colère des
défenseurs de roland dumas celui ci est
poursuivi je le rappelle depuis le 29
avril 98 pour complicité et recel d'abus
de biens sociaux au préjudice du groupe
elf explications avec olivier caroff la
correctionnelle
c'est ce que demande le procureur de
paris contre roland dumas jean pierre
dintilhac se montre implacable avec
l'ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel
dans ses réquisitions publiés cet après
midi par le journal le monde il écrit de
non réponse en omission fautive et de
demi vérités en véritable mensonge
roland dumas a démontré tout au long de
cette instruction une volonté délibérée
de dissimulation de quoi provoquer la
colère des avocats de l'ancien ministre
et quelques surprises
que j'apprenne pas la presse les
réquisitions du parquet avant qu'elle ne
soit déposée au dossier du juge
d'instruction et je dis que là nous
sommes en présence d'une situation tout
à fait scandaleuse tout à fait
inadmissible et qui porte un préjudice à
l'institution judiciaire
au coeur du dossier les accusations de
christine deviers joncour l'ancienne
maîtresse de roland dumas a vu son train
de vie prises en charge par le groupe
elf
longtemps elle a juré que roland dumas
l'ignorait puis elle a avoué oui elle
était payée par elf pour faire du
lobbying auprès de roland dumas oui
celui-ci profitait grâce à elle des
largesses du groupe pétrolier exemple le
plus flagrant
l'appartement du 19 rue de lille à paris
un cadeau quelle forêt promis à roland
dumas christine deviers-joncour
n'affirme certains témoignages le
confirmerait le reste tient d'un
catalogue du bon goût à la française
chaussures de luxe toiles de maîtres et
grands restaurants le tout payé pareil
c'est maintenant au juge laurence
vichnievsky eva joly de décider s'il y
aura procès les avocats de roland dumas
ne le cache pas ils s'y attendent à moi
de trouver un vice de procédure mercredi
prochain la cour de cassation doit
justement examiner une partie du dossier
ancien commissaire européenne mme edith
cresson et plusieurs fonctionnaires de
l'ex commission européenne présidée par
monsieur sans terre pourrait être amené
à s'expliquer sur plusieurs affaires
dont celle du programme baptisé leonardo
programmes de formation professionnelle
et celle concernant rené berthelot qui
fut chargé d'un rapport par madame
cresson
le procureur du roi de bruxelles aurait
envoyé une demande de levée d'immunité
judiciaire demain pression dès le mois
de novembre dernier
l'impression déclare ce soir j'accepte
bien évidemment que mon immunité soit
levé pour prévenir autant que faire se
peut de nouvelles catastrophes
écologiques comme celle de la marée
noire du pétrolier erika le mini jean
claude brisseau réunissait aujourd'hui
une table ronde sur la sécurité avec les
opérateurs du transport maritime
français ils sont nombreux des
initiatives sont envisagées en matière
de réglementation d'harmonisation des
contrôles on évoque la mise en place
d'un système d'information baptisée etc
oasis
permettant à partir de mai prochain de
connaître en temps réel l'état du navire
sa dernière certification son âge c'est
des changements éventuels de
propriétaires de son côté la société de
certification italienne rina qui fut
chargé du contrôle du pétrolier erika a
révélé aujourd'hui que tous les navires
jumeaux semblables l'erika on tue des
problèmes structurels
nos envoyés spéciaux patrick fandio et
adèle wesh était à gênes au siège de la
société rina où l'on évoque des
responsabilités très diverses y compris
celle du groupe total dans le naufrage
du pétrolier le 12 décembre dernier au
large du sud finistère
c'est donc lui voici l'homme qui a
décidé que l'erika était assez sûr pour
prendre la mer s'il ya nos pattes au
château est le directeur technique de
riina le bureau de vérification italien
et quand il nous invite à prendre
connaissance des premiers résultats de
son enquête sur les causes du naufrage
c'est tout simplement pour nous avouer
qu'il n'a pas de certitudes
juste une intime conviction nous sommes
convaincus que l'accident est lié à une
combinaison de facteurs
la fracture initial découle de plusieurs
raisons et quand elle s'est propagé au
reste du pétrolier c'est aussi à cause
d'un enchaînement de raisons antérieur
deux mois après rina a enfin identifié
elle aussi l'origine du naufrage une
fissure dans la structure de la coque
mais la société italienne estime qu'elle
n'en est pas responsable que le
chargement du fuel a peut être été mal
effectué par total à dunkerque que le
capitaine elle est peut être trop vite
dans une mère trop forte
rina met aussi en doute les réparations
doute 98 dans le chantier naval de
biella au monténégro c'est curieux car
ces travaux étaient supervisés par un de
ses propres inspecteurs loin de ceux
montrés embarrassés
le directeur pato fatto joue la sérénité
d'après nos informations nous sommes
convaincus d'avoir agi selon les règles
aussi nous considérons que nous n'avons
aucune responsabilité directe dans
quelques jours c'est au juge que rina
devra rendre compte comme tous les
autres acteurs italiens de ce dossier un
théâtre d'ombrés où décidément personne
ne veut être responsable de quoi que ce
soit deux autres informations sur ce
dossier on a appris la dissolution de la
société panship qui avait en charge la
gestion de l'erika et puis la levée du
contrôle judiciaire du capitaine de
l'erika enfin les opérateurs du
transport maritime viennent tout juste
de signer une charte de sécurité mais
pendant ce temps là sur les plages de
loire-atlantique de vendée du morbihan
le nettoyage continuent 1300 militaires
y participent notamment sur les îles de
noirmoutier bélisle et hoëdic
mais il faut aussi signaler qu'à
l'initiative d'un éducateur stagiaires
de l'administration pénitentiaire des
détenus en fin de peine du centre de
détention de nantes prêtent main forte
actuellement aux bénévoles qui gratte ça
buzz et rochers entre la baule et le
croisic pour cette initiative il a fallu
aussi convaincre différentes autorités
plutôt méfiante reportage louis carzou
et maggie gao arabe limur dans cinq
les miradors depuis quelques jours
charles découvre un nouveau décor celui
du centre d'hébergement pour les
bénévoles de la baule
car charles et volontaires pour aider au
nettoyage de la côte comme cinq autres
détenus en fin de peine
ce qui me chagrine le plus c'est de voir
dans quel état sont les plages ont fait
mais c'est un peu dommage que ce soit
dans ce cadre là qu'on nous ait permis
de sortir les barreaux il est mûr mais
on le fait avec plaisir et on va y
mettre tout notre coeur ce show-là
jusqu'ici les consignes comme
l'hébergement comme le matériel sont les
mêmes pour tous mêlés aux bénévoles
encadrés par les jeunes de la fédération
des maisons des potes
tout est fait pour que les détenus se
fondent dans le groupe pour certains
d'entre eux c'est le premier contact
avec l'extérieur depuis cinq ans alors
le plus dur à affronter ce n'est pas le
pétrole communication piment aux
commentaires parce que je me sens un peu
décalé par rapport aux gens
c'est quoi ce projet pour lequel il a
fallu choisir parmi plusieurs dizaines
de volontaires et obtenir à chaque fois
l'aval individuelle du juge
d'application des peines
c'est christophe du toit qui l'a initié
l'a voulu montrer qu'on pouvait imputer
les gens qui avaient la culture de
l'argent
ou un autre on est tenté par l'argent
facile ce qui les a amenés en prison
mais montrer que ma ces gens étaient
capables aussi de s'impliquer dans des
activités citoyennes une motivation
d'autant plus forte que chaque détenu
présent ici c'est qu'il sert de test
pour tous ceux restés derrière les
barreaux à longuenesse et qui voudrait
qu me donner du sens à leur détention
en plus d'être enfermés on a la charge
on est carrément complètement la charge
de la société et par payer alors ce
premier groupe de détenus devenue
bénévole assure le travail avec soin car
même le nettoyage des soudures de
l'erika c'est toujours moins humiliant
cannes horizon fait de murs et de
barreaux la carte scolaire pour la
rentrée 2000 est modifié pour les écoles
maternelles et primaires le nombre
d'emplois d'enseignants restera constant
indique le ministère de l'éducation
nationale qui rappelle que le nombre
d'élèves scolarisés dans le premier
degré diminuerait d'environ 20000 mais
le ministère reste plutôt très discret
sur les suppressions de postes
envisagées seul le syndicat des
enseignants de la fen publié un
chiffrage où l'on trouve des postes en
plus à créteil à la réunion ou encore à
nice mais des postes en moins à lille
amiens reims ou encore à dijon tout cela
reste flou et encourage les rumeurs
comme les grèves et manifestations qui
se produisent un peu partout en france
actuellement il y en a en seine-maritime
à besançon et toulouse et montpellier
la perspective de suppression de postes
un impact souvent très fort dans
certaines communes comme à port saint
louis c'est près de marseille une ville
de 8200 habitants
classé en zone d'éducation prioritaire
aujourd'hui c'était villes mortes à port
saint louis pour défendre l'école
reportage michaël darmon et jean
françois breau marc se défaire à les
imaginer votre école maintenant il y
aura vais m en moins et que vous serez
serré comme un vin d'honneur
les écoliers font leurs classes de
manifestants une chaise une table pour
deux ou trois élèves voient la mise en
scène à port-saint-louis la diminution
des budgets pour l'enseignement dans
cette commune située en zep zone
d'éducation prioritaire il est question
de fermer des classes pour le primaire
si on démolit des équipes aussi si on
nous prive d'un enseignant on pourra
plus travailler comme avant on pourra
plus travailler au niveau des enfants
défavorisés en effectif réduit
depuis quelques jours cette petite ville
de 8200 habitants a l'impression d'être
malmené par l'éducation nationale au
collège robespierre on attend des élèves
supplémentaires l'année prochaine alors
que des heures d'enseignement serait
supprimé professeurs et parents en sont
à leur dixième jour d'occupation
nous sommes vraiment désigné pour pour
être un collège qu'il faut qu'il faut
ménager puisqu'il ya des il ya des
problèmes bon on ne comprend pas
pourquoi tout d'un coup ses moyens qui
ont été accordées depuis depuis quelques
années diminue et le problème dépasse
celui de l'école port saint louis a
longtemps vécu grâce à l'activité
portuaire qui a déserté ce matin les
commerçants se montrer solidaire en
baissant leurs idées et il a mal plus du
jeune intellectuel ou les soins ceux qui
veulent gagner bourricot voilà je vous
le dis ce que je préserve la vie le
protestent parce que parce que tout le
monde est attaché à ce que
port-saint-louis arrive à sortir de
l'ornière et aya de l'avant ce n'est que
la semaine prochaine que les arbitrages
définitifs sur ici connu pour les écoles
primaires mais pour l'heure les rigueurs
de la carte scolaire semble enlever des
atouts à port saint louis du rhône
manifestations de quelques milliers
d'employés des hôpitaux de la région
parisienne aujourd'hui mais aussi à lyon
pour réclamer des budgets des effectifs
les personnels hospitaliers observent
des arrêts de travail depuis plusieurs
semaines dans plusieurs hôpitaux des
membres du tribunal de commerce de
beaune en côte d'or dont un juge ont été
mis en examen pour faux en écriture
publique
des associations de défense des artisans
et commerçants sont venus manifester
devant un tribunal de commerce de beaune
s'estimant victimes des abus et
dysfonctionnements de cette tribune le
11 février 1950 il ya 50 ans quel bel
âge le salaire minimum
interprofessionnel garanti était
instauré le smig cela fut perçu comme un
progrès une garantie on disait alors
qu'il devait représenter le budget it
d'un ouvrier manoeuvre célibataire de la
région parisienne
rappel sur ses 50 ans de smic devenu
smic en 1970 avec nathalie oiseaux
et tout commence en 1950 alors que les
pays se reconstruit les sadc de garantir
à tous les salariés un minimum vital
c'est l'objectif du smig salaire minimum
interprofessionnel garanti 1 et 50
années d'inflation en 52 le smig est
indexée sur les prix malgré cela il
prend du retard sur le coût de la vie
les événements de mai 68 change la donne
en une nuit
le smig gagne 35 % c'est l'une des
avancées les accords de grenelle
il était 3 heures précises d'abord sur
le smig salaire minimum garanti qui sera
porté à 3 francs au 1er juin 1968
pourtant un nom [ __ ] la vie est dure
pour se couper des semis gare avec trois
enfants alors me voilà nourriture payée
qu'est-ce qui voient là le font pas ils
devant la caméra monsieur mais la mode
us viennent se plaindre au ministre du
travail
nous voudrions savoir comment vous
feriez pour établir un budget avec aux
femmes afro et ça tombe bien le dit
ministre vient justement de créer le
smic avec un c comme croissance qui
change tout minimum tout est dans le tas
dernière lettre smic c'est garanti
pouvoir d'achat smic
depuis deux ans on dit c'est l'idée que
les plus bas salaires doivent également
participer aux fruits la croissance dès
lors le smic augmente tous les ans en
fonction du salaire ouvrier moyens 80 la
bouche augmente le smic de 10%
objet de toutes les critiques ce minimum
est accusé d' écraser l'échelle des
salaires
pire ils freinerait l'embauchent
ouvriers peu qualifiés mais en 94
l'échec du ces ip 10 smic jeunes met un
terme aux tentatives de réforme du
salaire minimum avec le développement du
temps partiel aujourd'hui 15% des
salariés gagnent moins que le smic alors
justement sur leur réalité du smic
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire sur celles et
ceux qui en vivent emilie lanson et
thierry breton suivi un jeune homme de
23 ans employé dans une entreprise de
maintenance industrielle à dunkerque
il est content bien sûr d'avoir trouvé
un travail mais sont pas trop explique
pourquoi selon lui le smic est une
lourde charge
yannick et nathalie vivent tous les deux
sur un seul salaire celui de yannick
5345 francs nets par mois le souk
il nous restons tous que mais une fois
que tout est pays 1000 francs par mois
une fois le loyer l'électricité et les
charges payées
c'est peu mais yannick est heureux
d'avoir trouvé cet emploi il y a un an
la d'envoyer des cv qui restaient sans
réponse
il s'est présenté ici au culot demandant
à être jugé sur pièce aujourd'hui ils ne
voient le smic que comme un salaire qui
permet de démarrer dans la vie
vivre toute sa vie avec 6000 francs par
mois il se moque aussi on peut on n'a
aucun projet je peux pas je peux pas
racheter gvt va pouvoir m'introduire
dans la vie active
acheter une maison fonder une famille
aussi
sur les 55 salariés de l'entreprise ils
ne sont que six à être au smic
les tout derniers arrivés à leur patron
qui se veut moderne compatibles je
m'aperçois comme je prends une fiche de
paye d'un asthme ik ben effectivement
que à la fin du mois il a pas grand
chose pour vivre 6890 elle renvoie la
faute est la lourdeur des charges
patronales
quand la personne regarde sa fiche de
paye qu'elle dise tout le ca 1500 francs
il coûte à l'entreprise 8817 rend donc
c'est un coup la france est l'un des
pays où les charges patronales sont les
plus lourdes 22 % du salaire
après l'allemagne le luxembourg la
belgique et les pays bas
c'est aussi le pays d'europe où le
salaire minimum est le plus élevé
alors bien loin du smic qui ce n'est pas
anecdotique
retenons le sort des casseurs de noix de
terrasson en dordogne se sont mis en
grève pendant quinze jours pour obtenir
une augmentation de revenus il faut
savoir que les nouveaux usages d'un kilo
et payer 3 francs les travailleurs
gagnent entre 6 et 12 francs par heure
mais la société qui commercialise leur
production n'a consenti que quelques
petits centimes d'augmentation comme
antérion fronty avec nos collègues de
france 3 limousin
il est terrible se brûla le bruit du
marteau brise en lannoy une petite
musique lancinante qui rythme le travail
de ses ouvriers d'origine turque ici des
familles entières passent leurs journées
parfois leur nuit a répété les mêmes
gestes pour trois francs du kilo ça fait
3 kg et ce qui fait nos francs c'est à
dire que tous les organes montrant assez
dur parce que l'on peut pas bouger on
est assis du matin jusqu'au soir
et il ya les familles qui travaillent
jusqu'à une heure et pour une heure du
matin
une tâche délicate il s'agit de fendre
la coquille sans écraser le fruit le
cern
tout cela dans des conditions de travail
rudimentaire alors pour continuer à les
accepter
ces ouvriers ont réclamé une
augmentation 50 centimes par kilo refusé
a dit le patron c'est la pression
concurrentielle des pays d'europe de
l'est et asiatiques qui vendent en
europe des produits très très bon marché
et le sable français perd des parts de
marché tous les ans s'ils se mettaient à
la place des gens qui cassent des noirs
à 3 francs il il a même reconnu que ce
n'était pas raisonnable compris est ce
qu'il aurait pas pu nous donner quelque
chose quand même
après plusieurs jours de grève ils ont
finalement obtenu gain de cause
leur patron ses sens d'une augmentation
10 centimes par kilo
c'est un rude avertissement pour la
thérapie génique des essais cliniques
ont été suspendues sur ordre de
l'administration américaine à
l'université de pennsylvanie la
procédure des expériences en cours
aurait entraîné la mort d'un patient
les généticiens affirme que ce sont des
pratiques qui sont en cause mais pas le
principe de la thérapie génique qui
portent évidemment tous les espoirs des
malades atteints de malformations
génétiques commentaires jean daniel
flaysakier c'est l'un des plus célèbres
centre de recherche au monde
mais depuis le 25 janvier l'institut de
thérapie génique de philadelphie ne
traite plus de patients sur ordre des
autorités sanitaires américaines
tout cela parce qu'un jeune patient est
mort en septembre 99 lors d'un
traitement expérimental la thérapie
génique c'est le grand défi de la
médecine aller au coeur des cellules
réparer un gène malade
un peu comme on a envoyé des pièces de
rechange dans une navette spatiale pour
réparer le télescope hubble
on veut pouvoir corriger la défaillance
d'un jeune malade en faisant apporté par
un vecteur souvent un virus le gène sain
qui palliera le défaut génétique
l'accident de philadelphie n'a pas
vraiment surpris les chercheurs français
notamment parce que le traitement a été
injecté directement dans le foie le
premier niveau est la voie
d'administration
on voit un travail pratique et une fois
que l'on sait toxique chez l'animal
notamment aux taux élevés
de virus la deuxième raison c'est les
quantités faramineuses d'un virus qui
administre achète passion on a en effet
injecté des doses
dix mille fois supérieure à celle
utilisée dans les essais français en ces
temps il y a eu six cent cinquante
incidents aux états unis et là encore
rien de surprenant je pense peut-être
qu'il ya beaucoup trop de sac unique et
il y en a beaucoup trop qui sont
inutiles vrai plus et c'est là qu'est
plus sélectif ou plus prudent et plus
prudent sûrement l'un des dangers
aujourd'hui c'est d'aller trop vite pour
des raisons d'argent aux états unis de
nombreuses sociétés de biotechnologie
finance les essais de thérapie génique
ces sociétés sont cotées en bourse et
pour faire monter les cours des actions
il faut des résultats à tout prix du
sport avec ceux de votre patinage
championnats d'europe de patinage
artistique c'est à vienne ont dans
l'épreuve de danse clé si le couple
français marina anissina et gwendal
peizerat sont toujours en tête
petit tel qu'il se rapproche de type
s'ils ont désormais effectivement de
bonnes chances de remporter le titre
européen il football avec un premier
match de demi finale de la coupe
d'afrique des nations disputée à lagos
au nigeria justement nigeria a battu
sans trop de difficulté l'afrique du sud
ce qui lui permet d'accéder à la finale
face soit au cameroun soit à la tunisie
comment t'as fait stèle bertrand un
match dense pour une victoire facile
le nigeria a nettement battu l'afrique
du sud
les nigérians démarrent le match en
trombe au bout de quarante secondes de
jeu babangida ouvre le score
les sud africains sont tétanisés
dépassés par le rythme imposé
pourtant privés locaux chaleur habituel
meneur de jeu les super eagles vont
trouver une nouvelle fois la faille
babangida encore lui et passe
définitivement les espoirs sud africain
score final 2 0 le nigeria se qualifier
pour sa sixième finale de la coupe
d'afrique des nations déjà victorieux en
80 et 94 ils vont tenter dimanche devant
leur public de remporter une troisième
fois le trophée contre la tunisie où le
cameroun en rugby on ne change pas une
équipe qui gagne bernard laporte concert
les 22 joueurs qui ont permis la
victoire 36 à 3 face au pays de galles
samedi dernier tout cela pour le
prochain match dans dix jours ce sera au
stade de france face à l'angleterre et
sur france 2 du tennis enfin à paris au
stade de coubertin dans le tournoi open
féminin bien déception anonyme aurait ce
mot pour elle a été battue sans
discussion mais par une autre française
brillante sarah pitkowski 6-0 6-7 6-2 du
théâtre dans celui du rond point à paris
judith magre interprète le journal de
charles ix après avoir joué seul en
scène cette pièce d'or du dernier
festival d'avignon judith magre est
admirable selon toutes les critiques
elle interprète une américaine venue à
paris dans les années 70 peintre faucher
pique assiette qui se raconte à une
table de bistrot
françoise roy et jean françois chevet
ont vu la pièce mardi 21 juillet 1971
aujourd'hui vers vos jours pour
recommencer un bon jour pour rester des
toiles une palette couteau et pour m'en
sortir
elle judith magre comédienne glamour se
devait de croiser la route d'une grande
excentrique sur les golfs hard
elle raconte l'histoire de cet artiste
méconnu je suis d'accord avec brigitte
bardot tous les hommes sont des brutes
et nous pourrions très bien nous en
passer
nous avons appris l'art subtil de la
masturbation judith je veux dire charles
et est assise au flore ou peut être deux
magots dans les années 60 elle n'est
plus si jeune un peu fofolle trop
maquillée tous ceux qui fréquentaient
saint-germain-des-prés se souviennent de
charles ix et peintre américaine venu
vivre à paris je porte ma binette pour
les pôles ce but m'a attrapé mes
sandales à plateforme que j'ai acheté à
venise l'été dernier point débardeur
bordeaux du monoprix de saint germain
des prés mon soutien-gorge transparent
bas petites culottes noires viennent des
galeries lafayette à l'époque alors elle
raconte son histoire drôle mordante
émouvante petite bonne femme à la fois
dérisoire et pathétique dans sa
souffrance dans sa solitude c'est
pourrait jamais faire ça son côté 6
chimiques sont sa faiblesse et son
arrogance
enfin y'a plein de choses moi je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes d'ailleurs
qui peuvent se retrouver dans charlie
avec humour délicatesse et une
incroyable tendresse judith magre nous
donne une heure de leçon de vie de rires
et de larmes
c'est rare des soutes est ce que c'est
un beau jour parce que grégory n'a fait
l'amour d'allah plein idées ou est-ce
que je suis trop con pour être
malheureuse je dit mack-kit hauteur du
rond point qui sera l'invité de thé ou
café dimanche prochain sur france 2
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de cette
édition je vous appelle l'information
sur laquelle le procureur de paris
monsieur dintilhac a rédigé un
réquisitoire implacable contre roland
dumas à l'intention des juges
d'instruction qui l'a mis en examen pour
complicité et abus de biens sociaux le
procureur demande le renvoi de roland
dumas en correctionnelle celui-ci ne
s'étonne pas d'être pris dit-il ce soir
pour un bouc émissaire
la météo dans quelques secondes avec
nathalie rihouet suivi du point route de
valérie maurice à 20h50
envoyé spécial présenté par bernard
benyamin depuis le brésil sur les sectes
dans le plus grand pays catholique du
monde où on se livre une véritable lutte
pour l'hégémonie de la chrétienté au
centre de cette bataille
l'église du royaume uni vers cette
nouvelle église secte un peu plus d'une
heure vous retrouverez laurence ostolaza
pour le dernier journal de rédaction
demain à 13h au travail car le dr rachid
arhab ici même et à 20h béatrice
schönberg alain dit bonsoir merci